But using the Atelier Robin down for many months, do you still think it's the best machine on the market?
My brother wants to get a Rife machine.
With your recall, we have switched to mainly recommending the Atelier Robin machine over the true Rife.
Back since last September, October when it came out.
Yes, there was some bumps along the road to begin with, but now we haven't had any issues with them at all.
Do I think it's a better machine?
Yes, because it does put out three times the voltage.
Do I think that it is the better machine because you can run
harmonics on it? To me, that's the best piece of it.
Also, you can run higher frequencies where you had to use the foot bath with the true Rife to get
the higher frequencies. The Atelier Robin lets you get up to the higher frequencies
that Royal Rife actually used. So, it has those three advantages.
The disadvantage, though I would say, is that it is larger. It's bulkier.
Patrick Robin may be working on changing that and redoing it just for us.
I've given him my request of how to reform the machine in different ways and things that we don't
need and things that I think will be better and improvements, and he may be making those changes
in the next full-out. So, if a person, we don't always recommend the Atelier Robin. So, we've had
people that you don't want it to write because they have a history of it to write. And that's okay,
I still, because I think the trip's still great machine. And then, or we've had people that,
hey, I travel a lot and I'm on the road all the time, then getting it to write makes a little bit
more sense because it's much smaller, easier to travel with, easier to put, to wrap in a couple
sweatshirts that put in a suitcase to keep it safe. And then it is the Atelier Robin. So,
there's pros and cons to each unit as far as having it at home and using it at home, using it overnight.
I think the Atelier Robin is the best machine. We have a number of people have both. They may have
started out with the trip and they added the Atelier Robin with the, you know, use one at night to
use one during the day so they have it in two different rooms. And so, that makes sense to, of course,
there's cost to it. So, I understand that that's how it was doable for everybody. But
if a person is calling and says, I just want to get the best one for me, it depends, again, partly depends
on, you know, what their personal conditions are. So, you know, if they just want one for home to use
if, you know, the kids got the flu or something like that, I think the Atelier Robin is much better
because if you're really using it, mainly to kill pathogens, being dealing with the
bone, you're dealing with bronchitis or dealing with tooth infections or dealing with ear infections
or something like that, running 11th harmonics is better and I wrote all the programs at the Atelier
Robin. Atelier Robin, I did not write all the programs of the true right. So, I had complete control
of all the programs and all the frequencies. So, those are our programs. So, I feel much more comfortable
and I feel much more comfortable with that. So, I feel much more comfortable with that. I feel much more comfortable with that.